she wasn't running away rather she was
moving toward a Stillness that she
wasn't able to find with this site
nearby I remember saying like all I want
is peace in the Years following the
Route 91 tragedy Anna Hendricks says she
did everything she could to regain a
sense of normalcy she went to therapy
she went to concerts she helped honor
the lives lost but Las Vegas which was
home just didn't feel the same I think
there's an underlying feeling that's
always there in the city and for her and
her three boys that meant it was time to
move on even to this day I love Vegas
but
um Tennessee's healthy for us
Tennessee's a is a place that I have
been able to heal it gets healthy for
them to see me healing when it comes to
dealing with trauma there really is no
right or wrong it's what works for you
Jackie Harris is a behavioral health
consultant for the Vegas strong
resiliency Center she's been counseling
survivors since that tragic night on
October 1st with trauma it's not
something we quote get over you learn to
live a full and healthy and happy life
Joanna says that life for her family is
in Tennessee it's different out here
it's very different it's healthier my
oldest said I would never leave here
because it's safe his birthday actually
falls on October 1st and Joanna says
this year they can finally celebrate
without the tragedy casting a shadow
this is the first year in five years
that it kind of just gets to be all
about him she says they'll continue
their 58 random acts of kindness to
honor the lives lost but this year
offers A New Beginning Harris says
Milestone years can evoke very strong
emotions so she reminds all of us
everyone heals at their own pace and in
their own time Heather Mills eight news
now